i think it goes without saying that
clearly some of the things that he has
raised in this podcast have been
hurtful to the royal family i think
particularly for the queen
and prince charles who are very private
when it comes to their personal emotions
i was liking it to truman show have you
seen that movie
between the truman show and being in a
zoo this idea of harry
venting airing
publicly his
private grievances is is going to be
problematic and i think it does raise
that really important issue of trust
i know that prince charles is really
keen to get his relationship with his
youngest son back on track it's why he
called that meeting
at windsor castle after the duke of
edinburgh's funeral he wants nothing
more
than to be reconciled with harry and for
this rift to go away and he's prepared
to work at it
but that issue of trust is one that
concerns him as much as it does
william they want to know that the
conversations they are having
are going to remain private and they
want to know that these conversations
are worthwhile
that they are making progress and i
think the problem is
with the podcast and the things that
harry has said particularly about the
institution
feeling like he was in the truman show
feeling like he was
in a zoo it's it's it has echoes of what
he said in oprah
that he and his brother and his father
feel trapped by the institution
it may be how harry feels but i don't
think it's how
william and charles feel when it comes
to parenting
if i've experienced some form of pain or
suffering
because of the pain or suffering that
perhaps my father or my parents had
suffered
i'm going to make sure that i break that
cycle so i don't pass it on basically
well i think the podcast was certainly
greeted with
surprised and certainly raised eyebrows
over at the palace
but i think the suggestion of this cycle
of pain
and that he talked about does seem to be
um
a criticism of his father of his
parenting and possibly even
a bit of a criticism of the generation
before that so
prince harry's grandparents so this
podcast i think has been received with
surprise
not least because it comes just months
after that
explosive oprah interview and at a time
when we were led to believe
the family were trying to repair this
rift
trying to mend some of those
relationships and try to move
forward i certainly think this has been
something of
a curveball thrown in the direction of
the royal family
i don't think we should be pointing the
finger or blaming anybody as parents we
should be doing the most what we can to
try and say you know what that happened
to me i'm gonna make sure that doesn't
happen to you his comments are
quite personal while saying he's keen
not to point the finger
it does seem that this is yet another
example of prince harry
criticizing the royal family in
particular his father who of course
came under some fire in that oprah
interview you'll remember that
prince harry said that charles's father
had turned off the financial tap
that he didn't feel his father had been
there and protected him enough
and i think there is that sense again
that he feels he's been let down by his
father in this interview that's
going to be incredibly hurtful for the
prince of wales when prince charles was
asked
if he was aware of his son's podcast
today on an engagement in cardiff he
pointedly refused
to answer i think harry knows that
they're not going to respond to this
they really have been rendered voiceless
and to a degree
quite powerless but there is of course
always two sides
to every story i don't want this job i
don't want to be here i don't want to be
doing this look what it did to my mum
how am i ever going to you know settle
down i have a wife and a family when i
know
that it's going to happen again really
certainly sources that i know
who are very good friends with the
prince of wales have always made it
abundantly clear to me that after
diana's death
charles made every effort to make sure
that diana's memory was
was very much a part of highgrove and
the london homes that the princess
shared there were always pictures
of diana so that her memory wasn't just
airbrushed out in history
so i think the suggestion that the
mistakes that
clearly prince harry feels were made in
terms of charles's parenting
have been repeated in his own experience
by his own father
is going to be very very hurtful and i
think if you look at how
prince charles of course he ended up
raising those two boys on his own after
the death of the princess of wales the
brothers both of them were given
a lot of latitude they were given a lot
of freedom they were given the chance to
make their own
life decisions so i'm not sure whether
harry's interpretation of this cycle of
pain is something that the prince of
wales would necessarily himself
either recognize or agree with and i
think
there is a feeling over here in the uk
that perhaps
no one has a problem with prince harry
talking about mental health
i think most people think it's an
important campaign and raising awareness
about it
can only be a good thing we want a
national conversation
but i think a lot of people here feel
that prince harry has overstepped a mark
in talking so personally about his
father
and his relationship with his father and
what most people have interpreted to be
quite a critical way my understanding is
that prince harry was very pleased with
the podcast he was very pleased to have
that platform
uh to reach out particularly to a
younger audience and
there is clearly a huge amount of
interest in the prince and in everything
he is doing in his new life
in la now over here there's a feeling
that he's constantly attacking the royal
family
he's constantly reverting to his past
and bringing up
difficult elements of his past rather
than looking forward to the future
i think certainly stateside there is a
lot more sympathy
for prince harry than there is over here
in the uk
well i think it was everyone's hope that
the duke of edinburgh's funeral would
preface
the thawing of ice we know that things
have been very very strange and
difficult
behind the scenes i i understand that
there were conversations on archie's
birthday
but things like this podcast which
really just
opens up yet another pandora's box
only set that healing process back 10
steps
i think it's inevitable that every time
harry speaks out about
personal family relationships it is
going to be damaging to the healing of
this rift
particularly between william and harry i
think there is a desire on the part of
both of the brothers to
move on to try and heal this
relationship will the brothers be
standing shoulder by shoulder on july
the 1st for the unveiling of the diana
statue
what's that body chemistry going to look
like and at the moment
we're still not 100 sure that harry is
going to be here for that statue
unveiling of course a lot of it depends
on when his daughter is born
and how megan is megan is due to give
birth
around june late june we don't have a
due date
and i think the reason quite simply that
prince harry hasn't booked a ticket yet
is because he is waiting to see he wants
to know that his daughter has been
born is safe that megan is safe and well
i think before he even thinks about
making any transatlantic trips one of
the things that that harry said in his
podcast was how it was his wife who had
encouraged him to go into therapy
it was a conversation that i had with
my now wife okay and she
saw it she saw it straight away she
could tell that i was
hurting and that some of the stuff that
was out of my control
was making me really angry and it would
make my blood boil
and i thought it was quite interesting
that he didn't mention william because
we know from his interview with bryony
gordon and the telegraph
when he first spoke about those mental
health problems and that crisis that he
went through in his twenties
when he was trying to process that grief
that suppressed grief over the death of
his mother
that it was in fact william who first
encouraged him to go into therapy i
thought it was very interesting
that there was no mention of william in
this conversation
it was all about megan and megan who had
encouraged him to go into therapy
unfortunately for the duke and duchess
of cambridge who have been doing a lot
of work around mental health awareness
week
here in the uk including a nationwide
radio campaign
encouraging people to talk out about
their mental health
a lot of the publicity that would have
been on that campaign has been deflected
by harry and this podcast which has had
some sensational
revelations in and really i think
revelations that people over here in the
uk
see us again damaging to the royal
family
quite disrespectful of his father and
now
even of the queen prince philip i think
it's absolutely the case that
mental health raising awareness is very
much on the duke's agenda we're
certainly going to see him and megan
working
in this sphere with their archwell
foundation and i'm sure that we can
expect when his apple series with oprah
airs later this month that we're going
to hear prince harry once again
talking about his own mental health
awareness talking about his own journey
through therapy
and more likely than not reflecting on
quite
personal circumstances that again risk
upsetting the royal family